guys i have to tell you
i am taking pleasure in someone else's
misfortune you know that the the german
term schadenfreude
means pleasure derived by some other
person's misfortune and i admit i am
taking pleasure in the fact that donald
trump's truth social app is collapsing
and has seen a 93
drop in sign ups
since the week that they launched i
don't take pleasure in the illness and
death of others even when those people
are disgusting when rush limbaugh had
lung cancer and died i said listen there
are people who love this guy and while
the globe may be better off with him not
doing his show i don't take pleasure in
illness or death i don't take pleasure
in the job losses of hard-working people
or the breakups of relationships that
are meaningful to others
but when you put up an obvious twitter
clone
and you claim that you're doing it
because they're censoring conservatives
on social media and
and then it fails miserably i love it i
absolutely love it this is a great
report from the rap the would-be twitter
killer has drawn only 1.2 million
installations according to sensor tower
former president donald trump's truth
social app
is seeing a 93 percent drop in sign ups
and similarly steep decline in traffic
after a rocky rollout last month fraught
with technical issues and an extensive
waiting list for new signups to actually
use the service after going live on
president's day the twitter lookalike
saw installs decline by more than eight
hundred 000 since it's launch week
installs on the apple app store this
month have fallen to about 60 000 per
week based on early estimates now if
you're like just some amateur app
builder and you're not putting out
something viral or whatever 60 000 app
installs a week really isn't bad we have
the former president of the united
states here channeling all of the
platforms and ability that he has as
well as his children doing it as well as
all sorts of his former staffers saying
this is going to be
god's gift to social media it's going to
dominate and then you open sign ups and
the website can't handle the traffic
initially people are put on a waiting
list then everybody just forgets about
it and doesn't care
and now nobody's even signing up and
both don jr and eric trump over the last
24 hours have tried to promote the app
try to resuscitate it bring it back to
life by posting how they are now on it
um eric trump tweeted yesterday i'm live
come join the party on untruth social
it's also kind of funny that it took
weeks
for eric trump to even get his account
activated so i love this tell me i'm a
bad person for loving this i'm ready for
it but this is a type of misfortune that
i absolutely take pleasure in just
another embarrassing humiliating failure
for the former president and we'll have
screenshots from the app and more
information about this i call it a
glorious failure i really do
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door ready to eat no
cooking no cleaning dishes saves you a
lot of time you can choose from over 50
hot and cold meal options there's
smoothies grain and noodle bowls soups
i'm a big soup guy many of you know that
i also really liked the vegan meatballs
with marinara noodles delicious
both eye and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good
for helping the environment the list
goes on i'm not vegan you all know that
i think but splendid spoon is really
great to just help me maximize the
proportion of plants in my diet splendid
spoon takes all of the work out of tasty
healthy plant-based meals and you'll
save thirty five dollars when you go to
splendid spoon dot com slash pacman the
link is down below